what did we look at last time as an idea
it was very closely related in fact I
almost felt it exactly the same way last
week what was the concept
right okay so let's repeat that again
slower and you don't need to write this
again for yourself like you had this in
your book already we talk about rates
and rates are about when you have two
quantities that are changing your
relationship to each other so examples
were things like kilometers per hour
that's a rate because you're comparing
two different quantities but importantly
this is what I want to emphasize these
units right they're different in fact
they have to be different because
they're measuring different things all
together like distance and time are
completely different concepts right so
rates like kilometers per hour or really
even looked at like say dollars per book
you remember when we were looking under
the linear relationships and we said
okay any time you want to compare two
different quantities you can draw a set
of axes euro line there and off you go
okay but again you've got two different
units that are being compared
now ratios are similar in that you're
still comparing three different things
but instead of comparing two things that
are very different to each other it's
where you're comparing two things that
are similar there are the same style so
ratios compare quantities with and I'm
actually going to say the way similar
rather than the same it'll explain why
in a second
okay rates are about comparing courses
different units like completely
different like qualitatively different
whereas ratios they're about saying
watched over two different things but
the tutor for these I measure them in
similar units okay
so here's an example I might say compare
two different distances so I might write
say 80 centimeters and this the typical
symbol for a ratio as opposed to a rate
which is like a slash is a corner like
that so I could compare this with say
this here okay so maybe this might be
the ratio of the length of you know the
height of someone's body vest is like
the length of their mom or something
like that these are still these are
still two quantities that are separate
to each other so they're different
things but when I look at them they're
actually the same kinds of units right
so they're both about length now being
that you're comparing two different
things that are really within the same
neighborhood right I actually don't need
to write the unit's ratios don't have
units at all okay so I would say I read
this is as 8250 okay now here's another
thing about this ratios follow all the
same rules as fractions in fact that's
why fractions are called if you remember
this all the way back from your seven
when you did fractions to decimals and
percentages we Colburn rational numbers
which doesn't mean Oh numbers that makes
sense okay it means numbers that are
ratio between two different things like
3/4 3 to 4 so I can just like I simplify
fractions I can simplify a ratio right
for example I could divide both sides by
10 that would be 8 to 15 same ratio all
of these ratios say the same thing so
what can we do with these things okay
what kinds of skills are you going to
deed to demonstrate well remember I said
there's similar units they don't have to
be identical okay for instance what
would be another common way to measure
someone's height not in centimeters but
in in what you can get affected go
period if you want more meters like
they're both common okay so I could have
written this pistol stating I could have
written this as 80 centimeters to 1.5
meters okay this is still the same ratio
I'm just using this skill we've been
looking at recently which is converting
units yeah yeah very good so what I'm
trying to get to is something like this
like this is as simple as possible right
and so if I got given this the first
thing I would do is I would convert the
units to be the same
once you've got them talking the same
language then it centimeters centimeters
do you notice if it was like 80 meters
to 150 meters it would still be the same
ratio it's just that everything would be
all hundred times bigger yeah it could
be 80 kilometers to 150 plumbers for all
like it it's still the same comparison
you're just drawing a really really big
object because okay sir the first thing
you'll notice is that just like
fractions you do everything with these
that you can do with fractions secondly
sometimes they don't come up with
identical units they're just similar
right like meters and centimeters and if
that happens the first thing you should
do is you should confirm secondly like
you can see this path that we went down
here I need another color this path that
we went down from the top to the bottom
is what we call simplifying a ratio just
like you would sin safai a fraction but
sometimes you actually want to do the
opposite you want to go from a simple
ratio to something more complicated so
let me give you an example here's a
question the question is extrapolate
which means take something small you
know extrapolate means infer something
general from a small amount of
information
I wasn't going to but okay so the idea
is and as I get through the question
you'll see what I mean take a small
amount information and try and get
something general comment
extrapolate the number of girls in the
school based on our class based on our
class
if I happen to know there are nine
hundred nine nine boys in the school
which is not exactly right but it's
pretty question okay so how am I going
to do this well first I begin by saying
what does it mean to base a you know a
generalization or any off val clunks
well in our class there is a ridge here
there's a different pair of quantities
that will help me work this out namely
the ratio between the number of boys and
the number of girls okay now when you
have a look around there's a grand total
of five boys in this house okay now we
will just we'll discuss the implications
is this so why what is a ratio of girls
to boys the ratio of girls to boys if
there are five boys in the closet how
many girls are so what I've done here is
I've written this as a pair of ratios
and I'm gonna try and make a comparison
between the two
now remember everything I said about
over here ratio is everything you can do
with ratios you can do with fractions
and if we did write them as fractions to
you that'll be more helpful to us okay
so instead of girls to boys and nineteen
to five I'm gonna write this as a pair
of fractions I'm gonna try and compare
here cuz I actually know some
information you that I can add into this
do you have a number don't don't give me
the only yes or no
okay now I know they're actually well
the question told me I know the number
voice well apparently magic so I'm
actually going to replace this with the
number of boys they are okay now you can
see if I want to work out the number of
girls like I'm just this is solving
equations you're back in am-1 right so
all I need to do is to say what do I do
to my science to have to solve for what
it's girls on its own and on the
left-hand side I'm just gonna multiply
through right so every year I have 1900
five times 999 okay your calculator to
view an answer for this right
mm thirty thousand seven hundred fifty
eight point two okay so before we
discuss this number and why it seems
like we should run this down because oh
well yeah not numerically okay so I'm
going to carry it to the nearest whole
number and they don't know to step back
now what we're trying to do is take this
small bit of information that is easily
accessible to us right this often is the
case where it's hard we discuss the
census before it is high and it's
expensive and time-consuming to do a
census it's why we do it very
infrequently so therefore it's like
would like if you ever wondered if you
hear on the news but there's an election
coming up they said okay look at the
polls right now the polls are clearly
not asking every single person who can
resolve voting ain't right because
that's called an election all they're
doing is they're looking at a small
bunch of people going to some areas
certain age and so on
and say well okay what's the ratio of
people who are gonna vote this way or
that way and then they try and take that
in patients say oh there's 20 million
people in Australia therefore what are
we likely to expect okay so this is the
ratio I observed here in this room and I
tried to apply it to the whole school
what do you think of that number this
much it does seem a bit much right why
is that why is it such an astronomically
large number
yeah very good so for example we already
put in this out right at the beginning
when we looked at this classmate both
really really okay so this is not a
typical in fact if you if you wait for
15 minutes and my you guys go out and my
you twelve class comes in it's not quite
but it's almost reversed okay so if we
took a few more classes the more classes
you take obviously the more accurate
you're going to get but you could wait
we're very wick very very we don't
represent the entire school which is why
this number just completely out of whack
okay but you can see how well you know
what people win the polls they do this
whole time right would you be surprised
if they went to a particular area or
Sydney and they just pull all the random
people who came by
well they might get a result that looks
like this and then we I believe that are
more boys
well we're trying to see how ratios can
be used the problem is not the person's
the problem is actually this is the
problem yeah it's the sample right is
the particular what we're going to look
at more this data and statistics so
that's the issue with using flawed data
well for sample sizes he's hitting a
difference right the difference is by
all of this logic is sound this logic
assembly if I found some class that was
the perfect like perfectly
representative the typical cherry row
class then we get exactly the right
number out the other end but I figured
it'd be a bit silly to take another
random class when we have a class
sitting right here and it brings up this
interesting discussion about why
okay